I have never gotten more requests in my
life for a review I should have never
told you guys that I saw it at Toronto
but I did so let's review this Cloud
Atlas is a film by the Wachowski brother
they're not brothers anymore
the Wachowski z' it's based off of a
novel which I have not read it stars Tom
Hanks Halle Berry this humongous cast
that I really can't even take the time
to name but there are so many people in
this movie and it tells a very intricate
tale over many time spans featuring
similar characters who look the same but
with various makeup adjustments that
tell a very similar and slightly
interconnected story over these various
times the future the past the present
all over the place this movie is there
is really no way that I can fully
explain the plot of this movie too
because it is just so big this movie is
huge it's like three hours long it is a
humongous epic and it's by far the most
challenging film I've seen all year 100%
the audience at TIFF I could tell
appreciated it but the overall vibe I
got from people were that they were
really polarized by it and I think that
eventually as more reviews come in and
more people see the film that will be
the initial response is definitely
polarizing it's movie you either love it
or you hate it and I'll be honest with
you I'm somewhere in the middle I don't
hate this movie at all it is way too
impressive of a movie for me to hate but
I don't love it and I'll explain why I
wanted to adore this movie I really
wanted to just flat-out love this movie
but there's something about it that I
had a hard time grasping and that is the
fact that it is horrendously confusing
and I don't just mean that it's hard to
understand but I got to be honest with
you I really didn't get a lot of this
movie and I feel like if you watch the
first like five minutes of this movie
because there's this big intro with all
this narration you see every single
character within these five minutes and
it's this really long monologue but all
the different actors after that five
minutes passes if you liked that then
you'll probably like the rest of the
movie you cannot deny the technical
ingenuity of this film though it looks
beautiful and there is just so much
happening that I cannot even begin to
think about how these people approach
this material because
it is just so huge there is so many
different things happening like Tom
Hanks and Halle Berry there's this one
story where Tom Hanks and Halle Berry
are like way in the past and then
there's one with their way in the future
and they all sort of carry the same sort
of themes throughout the film my
favorite one was probably this one with
Jim Broadbent where he was sent to this
senior citizens home and he had to try
to cook up a plan to escape with some
other seniors I really liked that one
that was probably my favorite one of the
most confusing ones for me was in the
future with Tom Hanks and Halle Berry
they had like this different form of the
English language I don't know what else
to call the future speak like they would
add extra syllables towards that we're
used to saying and actually had a hard
time understanding it for a while and I
had to kind of teach myself as I watched
the movie how to understand what they
were saying and that was kind of
difficult Tom Hanks Jim Broadbent I
thought these guys were definitely to
stand out to this movie there were good
performances for many people Hugh Grant
was barely in the movie at all Hugo
Weaving did fine and I gotta say I'm
impressed with this movie it's just so
polarizing I just I can't wait for you
guys to see it cuz I know that right now
everything I've read for this movie of
people's anticipation is so like
universally positive like everyone is
just frothing at the mouth for this
movie and I don't want to disappoint you
or make you feel bad but I just thought
it was too difficult to understand but
I'm going to recommend that you see it
because I really think this is an
important movie that's the weird thing
about this movie is I'm not seeing one
movie this year where I have been this
confused about the way I feel about it
upon leaving because I admired it and I
thought it was really impressive and
lots of things to commend about it but I
don't really know if I want to see it
again because it was just so so
difficult it actually felt like school
at times and if you're not familiar with
my reviews if you're new to this because
it's like the only cloud Eilis review
out right now know this I respect movies
that are difficult my favorite movie of
2011 was Drive and I think that is an
excellent film but it is by far not your
average you know film it's different I
like artistic movies so don't think that
I'm you know bad-mouthing this movie
just because it didn't have enough
action in it or because it wasn't matrix
II enough it was just very difficult to
understand and hard for me to latch on
to emotionally because of that so I'm
going to give Cloud Atlas a C+ a lot of
people are going to say this movie is
American cinematic masterpiece a lot of
people are going to say that it is an
absolute atrocity and a failure perhaps
50 years from now this will be today's
2001 a Space Odyssey I have no idea I
may be completely wrong about this movie
because I just didn't get it but I just
didn't really get it and I gotta be
honest with you guys I gotta keep it
real with you guys and maybe trust me a
little bit the movie is worth seeing
because I think you should see it
because it's just so different and
unique and original but a lot of you are
going to be scratching your heads and
wondering what you just saw for three
hours
I warned you guys that The Last
Airbender sucked a week ahead of time
before any reviews were out I warned you
guys about cars to not being that great
before any reviews were out I'm telling
you this movie is well done but it's
going to be polarizing trust me
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you liked this review then you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes